all right Jim listen up this clue is
about family but the game has changed
now
[Music]
[Applause]
Dominic Toretto just went rogue you're
gonna turn your back on family I know it
looks bad don't give up on I'm so easy
you've only got one chance to make this
family whole again you ready one thing I
can guarantee no one's ready for that
she's the very definition of high-tech
terrorism there's thousands of cars in
the city and now they're all night
now I know what it feels like to be
every cop ever tape enough white white
white
[Music]
ah Oh daddy
our paths have crossed before gone
needed been knowing I think I need to
remind you why you chose to be here I've
got no choice if you gotta catch doc you
got a new little help if you want to
tell me why you just put me in a room
with the tea and crumpets eaten criminal
nothing that tight t-shirts kind of the
circulation you're buying you should get
bigger size you guys are going to work
together I've been waiting for this we
got a tank now what's up Oh baby
ha ha
[Music]
you just don't give up today you thought
this was going to be a street fight is
that so get out take the wheel
what clanky ha ha you get style points
for that one I don't know why you're
doing this but I know you love me
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you